in the field of
biology the Holy Quran says in Surah
Alia chapter number 21 verse number
30 we have created every living thing
from water will you not then
believe imagine in the deserts of Arabia
where there was scarcity of water the
Quran says everything was created from
water who would have believed in it
anything else the Quran would have said
people could have believed water where
there was scarcity the Quran says 1400
years ago every living thing is Created
from water today we have come to know
that
cytoplasm which is the basic substance
of the living cell contains 80% water
every living creature contains 50 to 70%
water and without water the living
creature cannot survive it's a
must Quran asks
you we have created water every living
thing will you not then believe Allah is
saying that everything is Created from
water which you came to know today Quran
mentions that 1400 years ago will you
not then believe it's asking your
question it wants a
reply the Quran says in Surah n chapter
number 24 verse number 45 that we have
created every living animal from water
the Quran says in Surah fan 25 verse
number 5 before we have created the man
from
water imagine 1400 years ago the Quran
mentions this in the field of botony we
have come to know recently that even the
plants have got Sexes male and female
previously we not know that even the
unisexual plant has got distinct
characteristic of male and
female the Quran says in Surah Taha
chapter number 20 verse number 53 it is
Allah who sends down word from the sky
and causes diverse pairs of plants to
grow each separate from the other that
means the plants have got Sexes male and
female the Quran says in Sur chapter
number 13 verse number three we have
created every kind of fruit in pairs two
and two even the fruits have got Sexes
male and
female in the field of zoology the Holy
Quran says in Surah Anam chapter number
6 verse number
[Music]
38 that we have created every living
animal that lives on the earth and every
bird that flies on the wings in the air
to live in communities like you today
science has discovered that even the
animals and birds live in community like
the human
beings the Quran describes the Flight of
the bird in Surah Nel chapter 16 verse
number
79 that do you not look at the bird
subjected in the midst in the
air none of them can hold them up except
with the power of Allah subh tala the
Quran repeats in Surah multer 67 verse
number 19 do you not observe the birds
above
you they spread their wings and they
Fold It none can hold them up except
with the power of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala and he watches over all things
there is a very striking resemblance
with what modern science has discovered
today that the birds have got a certain
migratory
programming in the nervous
system that's the reason that young
birds without any prior experience can
take flights of thousand thousands of
miles without a guide and they come back
to the departure point also and a very
good example is given by Professor
hamburger in his book power and
fragility of the mutten bird the muton
bird lives in the Pacific it has a
journey of more than 15,000 mil and it
takes about 6 months and it comes back
to the departure point in a delay of not
more than one week
how is it
possible the scientists say there has to
be a certain programming of these birds
who programming them but naturally as
the Holy Quran says Allah subhana wa
ta'ala holds them up Arabic
word meaning to seize or to
hold the Quran says in chapter 16 verse
number 68 and
69 that it is the Lord who has taught
the
bees to build cells in Hills in trees
and human habitations and to eat of what
the Earth produces and to find the
spacious path of the Lord with great
skill what does the Quran mean by Allah
subhana wa ta'ala has taught the bee to
find the spacious path of the
Lord fwn fresh who a scientist he got
the Nobel Prize in 1973
when it
described the behavior of the animals
especially the communication method of
the
bee and today we have come to know that
whenever a worker bee finds a new flower
or a new Garden from where it can take
nectar it goes and tells its fellow bees
the exact Direction and map of that new
flower or garden it's called as the bee
dance only today we have come to know by
high photographic methods how is this
communication
given the gender used in the Holy Quran
in these verses ofah chap 16 verse 68
and 69 is a female gender K
ofi which means a female be previously
we thought it was the male bee which was
the worker be no wonder Shakespeare and
his play Henry IV he writes that the
soldier be the male be goes and report
to the King today we have come to know
it is not the king which they report to
it's the queen and the worker bee is not
the male bee it's a female bee imagine
Quran speaks about the gender of the
worker be400 years ago which we have
discovered today the Holy Quran
says in Surah anab 29 verse number 41
that as to those who take for protectors
anyone besides Allah subhana wa ta'ala
they build for themselves houses like
that of the spider and verily
The House of the spider is fragile it is
delicate besides the Quran saying that
anyone who takes for protectors anyone
besides Allah subhana wa ta'ala the
physical nature of the house will be
like that of the spider fragile delicate
flimsy it also gives a reference to the
family life which we have come to know
today that many of times the female
spider kills the male
spider the Quran says in Sur namal
chapter
27 verse number 177 and 18 that before
Solomon marched the host of jins mens
and birds and when they reached a lowly
Valley of ants one of the ants said get
ye into your habitations lest Solomon
and his host unknowingly will trample
you beneath the
feet people will think what kind of a
fairy tale book is the Holy Quran this
book the holy Quran it's speaking about
ants ants talking among themselves it's
a fairy tale book today we have come to
know that any animal or any insect which
has the closest resemblance to that of
the human being it is the ant the ant
bury the dead the same way as the human
beings do they have a sophisticated
method and division of labor where they
have manager supervisor workers Etc they
very often meet to chat they have
sophisticated method of communication
they have Market places where they
exchange
goods and when they store the grein in
Winter and if the grain begins to Bud
the ant cut the bud as though they knew
that budding will cause rting of the
Grain and Monsoon if the grain gets wet
they bring it out in the sunlight to dry
surely you might have seen the ants
carrying grains in the sunlight to dry
as though they knew that humidity will
cause
the development of root system which
will cause rotting of the grain so Quran
speaks about the advanced nature of the
ants 1400 years
ago in the field of
medicine the Holy Quran
says in Surah Nel chapter 16 verse
number 6 69 that from the belly of the
bee you get a drink of varying colors in
which there is healing for mankind
it's recently we have come to know that
the honey we have is derived from the
bee it's the bee which is responsible
for the honey we did not know about this
before and today we know honey has got
high nutritive values it's rich in
vitamin K and
fructose and it has got mild antiseptic
properties no wonder the Russian
soldiers they used honey to cover up
their wounds which prevented the
evaporation of
moisture and left very little Scar
Tissue any person
suffering from an allergy of a
particular plant if honey produced from
that plant is given that person starts
developing resistance to that
allergy in the field of
physiology it
wasf who 600 years after the revelation
of the Holy Quran described the blood
circulation and 1,000 years after the
revelation of the Holy Quran that is 400
years after Naf describ the blood
circulation William Hari he made it
famous to the Western World the food
that we eat it enters the stomach it
enters the
intestine from the intestine it goes
into the blood vessels of the intestine
and enters the blood
circulation and the blood circulation
takes the food
substance to where organs including the
mamory glands which produce
milk the Quran speaks about the blood
circulation and the production of milk
in a nutshell in Sur nelter 16 verse
number 66 where it says that verily in
the cattle is a lesson for you we give
you to drink from what is within the
bodies coming from the conjunction of
the constituent of the intestine and
blood milk which is pure and pleasant
for those who drink the Quran says
in 23 verse number 21 which is also
recited byari brother as muhammadi it
says that verily in the cattle is an
instructive sign for you we give you to
drink from what is within the bodies in
which there is various benefits and of
the meat you can eat Quran describes the
blood circulation and the production of
milk in a nutshell 14400 years ago
in the field of
embryology there were a group of Arab
students who collected all the matter in
the Holy Quran dealing with
embryology and they followed the
guidance of the Holy
Quran in Surah furan chapter 25 verse 59
which says if you are in doubt ask the
person who knows ask the person who
knowledgeable so they took all these
data given in the Holy Quran dealing
with embryology and presented it to
Prophet kitm Professor Keith Moore is
the head and chairman of the Department
of anatomy in the University of Toronto
in Canada and is one of the
leading authorities in the world in the
field of
embryology when Professor
Kitmore went through the translation of
the various ver the Quran dealing with
embryology he said that most of the
thing which the Quran speaks about
embryology is matching with the latest
discoveries made in the field of
embryology but there are a couple of
things which I cannot say that they are
right neither can I say that they are
wrong because I myself not know about it
and one such verse Wass from or alak 96
verse number 1 and 2 which says
read recite or Proclaim in the name of
th Lord who
created who created the human beings
from something which clings a leech like
substance so professor kitmo said I do
not know whether the embryo looks like a
leech or not so he went in his
laboratory and under a very powerful
microscope examine the shape of the
early stage of embryo and compare it
with a photograph of a leech and he was
astonished at the Striking
resemblance and when he was asked about
80 questions on embryology taken from
the Holy Quran and Hadith he said that
if you would have asked me all these
things 30 years ago I would not be able
to answer more than 50% of
this because embryology the development
embryology is just recently hardly 3 to
50 years it's
Advanced and profet Keith Mo has written
a book the developing human and in his
new edition the Third Edition he has
incorporated the new things which he
formed from the Quran and the Hadith for
which he got an award for the best
medical book written in that year by any
single
author
and when I was doing my mbbs in the
first year we refer to this book
developing Human by Keith Moore if you
wanted to score high marks in embryology
we refer to the book by Keith Moore if
you wanted to get just passing Mark we
refer to inder Singh but if you want to
score we had to refer to the book by
Professor kit Mo and later on this book
was translated into several languages of
the
world Prof the kitmo said I have got no
objection in accepting that Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him is the
messenger of God Almighty and that
the Holy Quran has to be a divine
[Music]
revelation the Holy Quran says in Surah
tter 86 verse number 5 to7 let now man
think from what he's created he's
created from a drop emitted from a space
between the backbone and the
ribs today we have come to know the
genital organs the testes in the males
and the ovaries in the female in the
emonic age they develop from a space
where the kidney is present today
between the backbone and the 11th and
12th rib later on the testes The Descent
to thean into the scrotum and the
ovaries in the female to the two pelvis
but in the embon cage it's in the space
with the Quran speaks about between the
backbone the spinal column and the 11th
and 12th rib
even in the adult life after the geneal
organs they descend yet they receive the
blood supply the nerve Supply and the
lymphatic drainage from the same space
between the spinal column and the 11th
and 12th
[Music]
Rim the Holy Quran mentions in Sur CH 23
verse number 13 as well as in Surah
alhaj chter 22 verse number 5 that we
have created the human beings from
anut the Arabic word nuta that the human
beings have been created from nah is
mentioned in the Quran no less than 11
times and the word nuta is mentioned 12
times but human beings created from nah
is mentioned 11
times the Arabic word nah means a minute
quantity of
liquid the Holy Quran
says in Surah sa 32 verse number 8
that we have created the human beings
from AC
quintessence of liquid the Arabic word
isala meaning a minute quantity or the
best part of the whole and today we have
come to know only one sperm actually it
penetrates the omam and only one sperm
is required to fertilize the ovam out of
the tens of millions of sperms which the
man ejaculates Quran refer refers to it
ASA the best part of the whole or a
minute
quantity the Quran says inah insan
chapter 76 verse number
two the Arabic word means not means we
have created the human being from a
minute quantity of mingle
fluids minute quantity of Mingle
fluid this can
refer to the male and female gametes
after they form the zygote it yet
remains a nuta a minute quantity of
liquid it can also refer to the
spermatic fluid which contains several
secretion from various glands like the
testes the cof fluid which contains the
spat zons it also
includes the secretion from the semal
vesicles the somal fluids which is a
reservoir of spato zones but does not
contain the fertilizing agent also it
refers to the secretion of the prostatic
glands which gives the creamy texture
and the characteristic odor to the sperm
as well as glands attached to the uni
tract the Cooper's gland or the litters
gland which gives the specific texture
of mucus to the
sperm the Quran refers to
as large minute quantity of mingle fluid
male and female gamits surrounded by
these fluids which are responsible for
the birth of the human
being the Holy Quran says in Surah Alum
chapter
39 verse number
six we have created the human beings in
the wombs of their mother in stages one
after the other in three Vees of
Darkness professor kitm said these three
Vees of Darkness refers to the anterior
abdominal wall of the mother the utrine
wall and the amnionic
membrane the Quran also speaks about
genetics the Quran
says in Surah naam chapter 53 verse
number 45 and 46 that we have created
the human beings and made them into male
and female from a minute quantity of
liquid which is ejacul
at but naturally if it's ejaculated it
has to be a male fluid Quran says it is
the male which is responsible for the
sex of the child the Quran repeats this
message in Surah 75 verse number 37 to39
that we have created the human beings
from a minute quantity of sperm and then
made it into an Al a Lee like substance
then gave it due proportion then made it
into sex male and female fale the Arabic
word means a minute quantity of sperm
Quran says a minute quantity of sperm is
required for sex of the child today's
science has come to know that the sex of
the child depends upon the 23rd pair of
chromosomes and it is the sperm which is
responsible for Deering the sex of the
child if it's x x it's a female if it's
an XY it's a
male Quran has mentioned this 1400 years
ago in our
society especially in the Indian Society
for reasons known best to them people
prefer having a male child and suppose
the daughter-in-law if she gives birth
to a female child the Mother-in-law
normally blames the daughter-in-law if
the mother-in-law has to blame anyone
she should blame the son not the
daughter-in-law because the Holy Quran
and science tells us that it is the male
which is responsible for the sex of the
child and not the
female the Quran describes the various
embryological stages in great detail in
Sur CH 23 verse number 12- 14 it says we
have created the human
beings from AC quintessence of
clay then made it into a drop placed it
into place of security and made it into
an alak something which clings a Lee
like substance made that alaka into muda
AED like Lamb made that MGA into isama
bones then clothed the is bones with Lem
that is
flesh and then made it into a creature
blessed is he the best to create this
verse of the Holy Quran from 12 to 14 of
Sur mun chapter 23 describe the
embryological stages in great detail it
starts with saying we have placed the
nuta the minute quantity into k a place
of security today embryology tells us
that the embryo is protected posteriorly
by the backbone and the posterior
muscles of the mother anteriorly by the
anti- abdominal wall by the utrine wall
as well as the amnionic membrane it
continues then we made it into an alak a
leech like substance something which
clings the Arabic word alaka has got
three meanings something which clings a
leech like substance as well as blood
clot
alhamdulillah all three meanings are
applicable here because the embryo in
the initial stages it clings to the
utrine wall of the mother it looks like
a leech as confirmed by Pro Ki Mo it
also behaves like a leech it behaves
like a blood sucker it derives the blood
supply and the nutrition from the mother
and at this stage if an abortion takes
place the concept is it looks like a
blood clot it looks like a blood clot as
well as a leech so Quran in one word it
implies three meanings which all are
applicable Quran mentions this word
alaka no less than six times twice in
suron 23 verse number 12 to 14 Surah Haj
22 verse number 5 Surah GA CH number 40
verse 67 Surah 75 verse 38 as well as in
Surah ik 96 verse number two six times
it's
mentioned previously in the 17th century
people thought that the sperm it wed a
miniature human being a miniature human
being was present in the head of the
sperm which later on developed into the
uterus of the mother as a newborn baby
this was believed by swam Dam who
proposed the perforation Theory later on
when they discovered that the ovam is
bigger than the sperm degraph and others
they said it is not the sperm which Wass
a miniature human being it is the ovam
which vs a miniature human
being later on Ma parti in the 18
Century he proposed the biparental
theory that both are responsible as the
Quran says both the sperm and the OM is
responsible for the birth of the child
Quran says we made that alaka into Auda
muda means chewed like lump or something
tacky which can be put in the mouth
Professor Kei Moore said both these
meanings applicable because it is
something Taki which can be put in the
mouth and later on he took a plastic
seal and bit it between his teeth to
look like a muda a chewed like Lum and
he was astonished that the teeth marks
resembled the somites from which
develops the spinal
column the Quran says we made that mud
into isaman bones we clothed the isaman
with flesh and
muscles Allah says then we create the
alha stage we create a new creature what
does the Quran mean we have created a
new creature s tells us that the
embryological stages of development
before this stage in the rabbit in the
fish in the other animals it's similar
to that of the human being it's only at
this stage of alasha that the particular
characteristics of the human beings are
seen the head the hands and the feet the
Quran says we have made a new creature
and ends by saying blessed is he who's
the best to
create imagine Quran gives the various
embryological stages in great detail
there are the person who put for an
argument it's nothing new maybe some
Arab he opened up the abdomen of a
pregnant woman and checked the shapes
and wrote in the Quran he didn't realize
that all these stages with the Quran
describes it cannot be observed with a
naked human eye you require a very
powerful
microscope when Professor Marshall
Johnson was asked to comment on these
verses he the head of the Department of
anatomy in the Daniel Institute in so
Thomas Jefferson's Hospital in
Philadelphia USA he said it can be
possible that Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him he had a microscope and he
observed it then he was
reminded that microscope was not
invented 1400 years ago so Professor
Marshall Johnson laughed loudly and he
said yes I know
that and I've seen the first microscope
with my own eyes it hardly enlarges to
10 times and the picture is not even
clear then he said these stages has to
be a divine
revelation we further asked to comment
on the verse of the Quran from Surah alh
chapter 22 verse number five which says
we have created the human beings from
dust then made it into an made it into a
mud partly formed and partly
transformed
when you take an inis at this
stage and analyze the embryo and cut up
the internal organs you'll find out that
the internal organs at this particular
stage some of the organs are formed
while the other organs they aren't
formed so Professor Marshall Johnson
said if I said that it is a complete
creation I'm only describing those
organs which are formed if I say it's an
incomplete creation I'm only describing
those organs which are not formed there
can be no better description than the
Holy Quran saying partly formed and
partly unformed because some organs are
formed the others are not formed some
cells are differentiated the others are
not
differentiated Prof kitm said that today
in embryology we have got several stages
of the embryological development but it
is so
difficult to understand it because it
has got numerical stages stage one stage
two stage
three the Quran bases the stages on
shapes and prenal development Which is
far superior and easy than what modern
embryology has done
today if the embryologist they describe
according to stage of the Quran it's far
more easier for them to describe and
understand than what modern embryology
has done stage one stage two stage three
the Quran says in Surah abasa chapter 18
verse 19 and 20 we have created the
human beings from minute
quantity and we have made the passage of
birth
easy people normally wondered that how
can the birth canal which hardly admits
three to four fingers how can a baby
come out of it the Bony structure is so
rigid it has got ligaments how is it
possible Quran says Allah makes the
pathway easy and today we have come to
know that how is it possible relaxin is
being secreted by the ovaries and the
placenta which loosens the ligaments of
the pelvic joints and softens the cervix
the uterine contraction that take place
it pushes the baby downwards in the
birth canal the bag of water which
ruptures it provides a slippery surface
for the baby to come out to slide and
the various movements of the baby while
birth facilitates the movement through
the irregular pelvic joint Quran says
that Allah makes the pathway easy Quran
is giving you signs it's showing you
various emical stages who could have
described all these stages they asking
you a question will you not then
believe will you not then believe in the
Holy
Quran the Quran says in s chapter 32
verse number 9 we have given the human
beings The Faculty of hearing and sight
it's repeated
in Sur insan chapter 76 verse number two
we have given the faculty of hearing and
sight to the human being today we have
come to know the first sense to develop
is the sense of hearing Quran says first
hearing then sight by the fifth month of
pregnancy it's complete the year later
on in the seventh month of pregnancy the
I spits open imagine Quran gives the
order first comes hearing then comes
sight prophet
AR who's an
expert in the field of marine geology
who's
teaching in the University of King Abdul
aiz in jedah he was asked to give his
comments on a words of the Holy Quran
from Surah n chter 24 verse number 40
which says that the state of the
unbeliever is like the depth of darkness
in a vast deep
ocean
overwhelmed with waves topped with waves
topped with dark clouds the depths of
Darkness one layered over the other when
a man stretches out his hand he can
hardly see
it Allah gives light to who he wishes if
he does not give light you cannot
see Professor
durar he
said that this verse of the Holy Quran
is not speaking of about a normal sea
it's speaking about a deep
sea and today only with the help of
things like submar we have come to know
the depths of the ocean is dark
previously we not know that because a
man cannot go uned more than 20 to 30 m
underwater and if he goes more than 200
M uned he
dies it's today we have come to know by
the instruments that we have that the
depths of ocean is dark and he said this
darkness is due to two phenomena first
is due to successive absorption of the
color in layers as we all know the light
has got seven colors and we learned in
school for remembering easy VIP G the
colors of the rainbow viip g v for
Violet I for Indigo B for blue G for
green y for yellow o for orange red R
for red whip G
colors professor durar said that when
the light enters the
ocean by the first 15 to 20
M the red color is
absorbed and if a man goes underwater
about 30 m deep and if he
bleeds if he has a wound he will not be
able to see red color of his own blood
because red color does not reach there
later on 30 to 50 m absorbs orange
yellow is absorbed by next 50 200 M
green by 100 200 M and blue Beyond 200 M
and violet and indigo much above 200 M
therefore the layers of Darkness you see
in the ocean is due to the absorption of
light in successive
layers the second reason for these
layers professor durar said is due to
barriers
like the clouds when the sunlight hits
the cloud the cloud absorbs the light
therefore there's Darkness below the
cloud then the light is
scattered after getting
scattered hits at The Superficial waves
of the ocean this is the second barrier
the waves reflect the light further The
Superficial waves of the ocean those
light rays which are not reflected they
enter the ocean
therefore you have two types of layers
in the ocean The Superficial layer and
the Deep layer The Superficial layer is
warm and lit up the Deep layers they are
dark and this superficial and deep play
of the ocean it is divided by internal
waves we human beings did not know that
even there were internal waves we only
knew of superficial waves it was only in
1900 that we have come come to know that
there are even waves deep in the water
they are known as internal waves which
divide The Superficial part of the ocean
and the Deep part of the
ocean imagine the Quran mentions that
the
unbelievers state is like the depth of
darkness in a vast deep ocean
overwhelmed with waves topped with waves
that means deep waves are there internal
waves are there topped with superficial
waves
and it further continues topped with
dark clouds the clouds are the barriers
and even the clouds and layers and when
a man stretches out his hand he can
hardly see it only if Allah gives light
can they see it even the fish that swim
in the Deep part of the ocean they
cannot see unless they have their own
light with
them they have their own light with them
even the submarine that goes under water
it carries its own light otherwise they
cannot see
underwater so when Prophet durar was
asked how come this is mentioned in the
Quran 400 years ago he said it's
impossible for any human being to
mention this was this Quran has to be a
divine
revelation the Holy Quran says in
Surah chter 75 verse number 3 and 4 the
unbelievers
ask that how will Allah subhana wa
ta'ala be able to reassemble our
bones Allah says
we can not only reassemble the bones we
can even reconstruct in perfect order
the very
fingertips when the unbelievers say
after we are buried after our bones have
got disintegrated how will Allah subhana
wa ta'ala on the day of judgment
reassemble our bones so Allah says he
will not only be able to reassemble the
bones he can even reconstruct your very
finger tip in perfect
order it's referring to the fingerprint
method which was discovered by S Francis
gold in 1880 and he said that no two
Fingerprints of two individuals are
equal even in a million people no wonder
the police the C the CIA the FBI they
use fingerprinting method to identify
the culprit Quran speaks about that 1400
years ago Allah can not only reassemble
the bones he can even reconstruct in
perfect order the very
fingertips Allah subh
is asking you in 4 verse
82 do not you consider the Quran with
care do not you ponder over the Quran
with
care that if it had been from anyone
besides Allah there would have been many
contradictions there would have been
many discrepancies Quran is giving you a
challenge here is the Holy Quran try and
take out a single discap y try and take
out a single fault in the Holy Quran
it's giving you a challenge an open
challenge why don't you analyze the
Quran with care had it BR from anyone
besides Allah there would have been many
contradictions I would like to end my
talk by giving the example of prophet
Tashan previously the doctors they
thought that only the brain was
responsible for feeling of pain it's now
we have come to know that there are
certain receptors in the skin called as
pain receptors which are also
responsible a feeling of pain no wonder
when a patient of burn injury comes to a
doctor he takes a pin and he Pricks it
in that area if the patient feels pain
doctor is very happy it means it's a
superficial burn the pain receptors are
intact if he does not feel pain it's a
deep burn the pain deceptor have been
destroyed the Quran says in Surah n 4
verse number 56 as to those who reject
our signs we shall cast them into the
Hellfire and as often as their Skins are
roasted we shall give them fresh skins
so that they shall feel the
pain Quran says if your skin is roasted
we shall give you fresh skin so that
you'll feel the pain giving an
indication there is something in the
skin which is responsible for the
feeling of pain indication of the pain
receptors when Prophet T Tashan
who is the head of the Department of
anatomy in changma University in
Thailand he was given the translation of
this verse and he has spent a lot of
time in doing research on pain receptors
he said it's impossible that Quran can
mention this we discovered it recently
how is it possible he did not agree with
it later on after checking with the Holy
Quran after verifying the Holy Quran he
was so
impressed that in the eighth medical
Saudi conference in Riyad in the
conference he said
shill Muhammad there is no God but Allah
and Prophet Muhammad is the messenger of
Allah
subhana